Hi I'm Jake Kitchener, I'm a Senior Technical
Staff Member here at IBM Cloud and the Lead
Architect for IBM Cloud Satellite, an exciting
product that we have available for you now in
IBM Cloud. What is IBM Cloud Satellite? IBM Cloud
Satellite is a platform service that allows us to
expand the reaches of IBM Cloud to infrastructure
outside of IBM Cloud data centers. A powerful
technology if you want to be able to consume
cloud services, but you need to be able to use it
closer to your data, whether that may be in your
on-premises data center, on another cloud provider
where you may have a data lake, or potentially
it's sitting on your desk like I have right here.
Today I've got three Intel NUCs that I'm going
to be using to set up a Satellite location
which I think is pretty cool. It's kind of like
any sort of store kiosk that you might need to
set up and it's a great example of the power of
using distributed cloud with IBM Cloud Satellite.
So to get started, the first thing I need to do is
log into the IBM Cloud console and navigate over
to IBM Cloud Satellite. Once I'm there, I'm going
to go ahead and create a new location to represent
my desk. I'm going to go ahead and click the
create location button, give this location a name,
and click create. Pretty straightforward. Now,
once that location is up and running what I need
to do is bring some of my infrastructure on board.
To do that I'm going to navigate over to the Hosts
section which is the concept that we use in IBM
Cloud Satellite to represent the idea of systems
that are outside of IBM Cloud as the host. The
first thing I need to do is click on Attach host.
I'm going to go ahead and download this post
provisioning script and then once I've got that
in my hand I can go apply that post provisioning
script to any system on the planet. That could be
in another cloud provider, it could be in your
on-premises data center, or in this case I want
to get it bootstrapped onto these Intel NUCs that
are sitting on my desk. Now to do that i've built
a custom image that will automatically carve up
these systems into virtual machines and bootstrap
them with my post provisioning script. So all
I need to do is get this onto that USB key,
insert it into my Intel NUCs, and go ahead
and power them on. Now I'm going to go ahead
and go through that process for all three
of these because I want a highly available
setup. So I can do maintenance by removing
these later on, but that's pretty much it.
Now that those systems are online. We can see
they're all up here and ready for me to use in
my Satellite location and I'm going to go ahead
and get one from each of those systems assigned
to be my Satellite Control Plane. This is really
the heart of IBM Cloud Satellite that allows us
to build a secure way for us to go manage cloud
services into your IBM Cloud Satellite location.
Now I've got these hosts assigned,
my location is in a normal state,
and I'm ready to start using IBM Cloud Services.
Let's go ahead and take a look at what that
experience is like. I'm going to navigate over to
the IBM Cloud Catalog and I could choose any of
the IBM Cloud Satellite enabled services that we
have available. Today we're going to demonstrate
Red Hat OpenShift on IBM Cloud, but it could be
other services as well like our Postgres database
or potentially maybe some of our Cloud Pak for
Data as a Service options as well. So let's go
ahead into the catalog to Red Hat OpenShift
on IBM Cloud and we can see I still have my
traditional cloud service options where I can
provision into IBM Cloud data centers like a VCP,
but I've also got the Satellite option available
to me as well. So I'm going to go ahead and
choose Satellite. Choose my new location I
created and go ahead and give that a name,
and then create that OpenShift cluster.
Now, I can navigate over to my OpenShift clusters
in IBM Cloud and we can see I've got a number of
clusters in here, some of them are located in IBM
Cloud, some of them are in Satellite locations,
but this one is on my desk. Let's go ahead and
see what that looks like. I’m going to click
over to my cluster here and I can see I’ve got all
the normal service options that I would have for
Red Hat OpenShift and IBM Cloud, I can update the
version of this cluster to the latest version of
Red Hat OpenShift, or I can go in and perform
maintenance on my worker nodes as well like
providing updates to them. I’m going to click
over to my cluster here and I can see I’ve got
all the normal service options that I would have
for Red Hat OpenShift and IBM Cloud, I can update
the version of this cluster to the latest version
of Red Hat OpenShift, or I can go in and perform
maintenance on my worker nodes as well like
providing updates to them. I get the standard user
experience with single sign-on from IBM Cloud into
Red Hat OpenShift and all the usual tools that I
would find in in Red Hat OpenShift are available -
I’ve got all my logging tools my monitoring tools
the registry, all of the development tools that
are available to users of Red Hat OpenShift.
So, very powerful tool that we've got available to
us here that allows us to really expand the reach
of IBM Cloud and the powerful Cloud services
that we provide - in this case on my desk,
but remember, it could be on any infrastructure
in the world running Red Hat Enterprise Linux.
Thank you for watching. If you have questions, please drop us a line below.
If you want to see more video like this in the future, please like and subscribe.